this has been the talk it's been a long
time in the making I've been like
Newling about this topic for a very long
time and I've been actually meaning to
give a presentation about this for a
really long time so the fact that I'm
here and giving it today force me to
actually put it together so so really
excited about that alright so again I
just want to say you know disclaimer I'm
affiliated with a bunch of organizations
so this is standard the views expressed
here are mine and mine alone not
associated with anybody I'm affiliated
with those who know me know the
organization's I'll get into that in a
second so let's get that out of the way
okay so I want to start with asking a
couple questions because I wanted to
sort of set the stage set the tone for
the for the presentation so raise your
hand if you've used Hadoop spark and or
big data tools okay so a couple of you
have that's good sort of next question
this on a virtual machine on pseudo
distributed mode okay I thought it would
be more but that's fine on the cloud
okay on a managed cluster what I mean I
manage it's like not something you've
set up yourself just kind of work i'm
sort of existing video compression
system or something okay who has
developed the Python or our script to
use with it was dreaming oh so I'm
curious to know what the other folks are
using does it work on your local machine
usually yes right do you use additional
libraries or packages when you do Hadoop
streaming oh okay maybe I have the wrong
audience but then again what happens
when you start a cluster it works in
your local machine you have a bunch of
libraries and they use star cluster and
priority or shooting script pythons
River our spirit on the pod what's going
to happen out of the box like you start
an AWS TMR cluster out of box and if i
write in our script with you know some
additional library
does it happen it's gonna break why
because those libraries that you use
when you develop your strip locally on
your machine are not on a cloud are not
in every good on your cluster so it's a
little notebook it's not a little known
I mean if you use an excuse you used to
do streaming in the past you probably
know this but for those folks that don't
is this is tricky and this is kind of
like the idea this is sort of things
that I want to talk about today is i
really want to set the stage and i just
want to give you a set of tools and
ideas of things to think about as you
transition if the books that have
experience working with cloud you know
maybe already know some of these things
but for those of dog you know as you
think about transitioning from dealing
with data on your local machine two
things about so all right on a managed
system or whatever so um you know like i
said before it's there are a lot of
tools out there you know there's amazon
there's google there's Cloudbreak i mean
there's a lot of Managed Services
there's a lot of tools out there that
allow you to use these kinds of setups
to do the data analysis to set up
cluster etc but getting it right out of
the box like out of the box is about
eighty or ninety percent of what you
need it's sort of that extra last ten
percent of customization that usually
that's where different peoples but most
of the time trying to get it to work the
right way and that's what this talk is
going to be about you know you want to
spend your time really focusing more on
doing the actual analysis then doing
system administration or kind of DevOps
or you know whatever whatever we want to
call this but you have to know or you
should just have to understand what's
what's what's what's entailed when you
make that transition again the current
offering so I'm going to talk a lot
about Amazon Elastic MapReduce because
that's the 1 i've used the most that's
the one I'm most familiar with and
that's what I'm using for longest time
so I love amazon i love i love the set
of offerings you know i love the idea
that i can actually start a cluster on
the fly and start you
nope the problem is that to get it to
how I want it to work it's it's it's
been challenged and it's been a couple
this sort of the ideas expressed here
has been sort of many years in the
making and this has come up a lot in in
my teaching so you know I want to be
able to have an environment people are
comfortable with when I teach especially
because a lot of those folks are
teaching to our folks I know far and or
Python they're not job developers and
you know there are other tools out there
there's pay your tithe and whatnot but
the idea here is to really use our and
or Python as your interface to the clap
because that's what most people I think
want to use that's what people most
people are interested in using that's
what we're most comfortable with so a
little bit about me I know there's a lot
of familiar faces in the room so for
those who don't know me again mark
baseman I'm currently a scientist allen
hamilton we are hiring so if you're
interested come talk to me if you have
security clearance it better I am a
master day Timandra so you know I make
it work I make you dance i'm the
co-founder and board member of data
community see so raise your hand if
you've been to any more events okay
raise your hand if you've never heard of
the immediate DC okay so some of you
have something happen so David be a DC
is a organization we started a few years
ago basically centered about building
community for data DC area we run a
bunch of video we have eight different
meetup groups under Arella we have a
regional about 16,000 people right now
there was actually a couple of dignity
folks in the room then until me and some
of the original founders i coordinate
the sets Burnham in DC meet up so we
focus a lot about things on like how so
how to do the assigned stuff with our
Android pipeline and other open source
tools sometimes not open source things
like Sasson itself as well doesn't know
me I'm an art lover and advocate so you
know I was a little weird about giving
it our presentation at
fun event but it's okay I also teach as
I said before I teach at Georgetown into
GW and I've been teaching kind of big
data stuff for a couple years and i've
been i've been working with big data
tools for the role several years and
also i have to overlie publications once
called analyzing analyzers and when is a
chapter in the bad date handbook so that
ops i sort of a tricky term right and i
think it's really a tribute term because
it can be many different things for many
different people same thing as data
science right like take these lines
intersected with that office and you
kind of get sort of weird Venn diagram
but I put up here the industry
definition again you don't have to read
it but essentially it's really more
about using agile methods for system
maintenance system development that kind
of thing you know the global dev up is
to improve the relationship etc I'm
borrowing that term really in the
context of data science what it means to
me and sort of what it means today for
the purposes of today's presentation is
it's really a broad set of complementary
skills and knowledge that allows data
scientists and analytic practitioners to
set up their environments and access
system and data to work with it's you
know it's I've seen this I've seen this
many times it's really a challenge right
you um you want to get the right tools
to do the right job and sometimes just
like finagling with this set of tools to
get it to work the way you want it is
particularly challenging especially when
dealing with servers and Linux and
Hadoop and Java and environment
variables and all these sorts of things
so I mean you could call that sysadmin I
call that DevOps whatever so on that
note you know maybe the maybe I pick the
wrong title for the talk i don't know
maybe this should have been an advanced
command line hacking for data science
maybe should have been data engineering
for data science maybe you should just
be setting up a ideal big data
environment for research the point I'm
trying to make is that
data science DevOps is a loaded term but
what it really means what I wanted to
mean in this sense is the reality that
the reality of working with Hadoop and
big data tools is that there is a lot of
systems knowledge that needs to go in
there for you to be able to be effective
with your job again you know you can do
a lot of things out of the box I'm not
saying you can't you could start up a
cluster with Amazon's elastic MapReduce
you know if your data is on that
straight and you're doing something
simple like you know like running an R
script or Python script with streaming
without any libraries that works right
but it gets a lot trickier let's say
when you want to set up what I think or
what I like to call the ideal data
science environment again this is ideal
for me I think it's ideal for many folks
but but these are the kinds of things
that that I would like to see in sort of
a set of tools that I'm going to work
with and be comfortable with so of
course the latest version of Hadoop and
associated services yarn and spark and
pig and hive and whatever i'm not going
to focus on some of the other things in
the Apache Hadoop ecosystem like I don't
like school or anything like that that's
more I've got to leave that for the data
engineers but I'm focusing more on
analytical tools which i think is what
most of us deal with perhaps on a
day-to-day basis um you know as an hour
person i tend to use lots of packages I
yeah
can ya let me can you hold that thought
and then I can certainly answer that at
the end but yeah I can open a dress that
certainly and I'm going to stay here
because I need to stay here for the
audio to be captured in the video so
again you want to have the latest things
again as an our user I like to use our I
really liked or I want to be able to use
our more as the interface to the cluster
I mean I can sort of interface with the
cluster via the command line and other
ways but for folks that are new to this
this this ecosystem it can be it can be
a little bit intimidating so people want
to use the tools that they are familiar
with again you might want to use our
students to use our to have our and like
this version of our in packages the
other things to use our studio as your
IDE right so so again installing these
things the installation part is really
not that difficult it's the
configuration and I'm not really going
to get to to detail into the
configuration but I do want to raise the
issues and show you how what types of
tools you can use to to deal with this
again anaconda Python why on a condom
because it's got all the different
libraries associated with Python um you
know spark our PI spark those are
actually I think smart bar and pi spark
as far as i know are actually being
shipped with i think as of stops part 14
16 like they're actually part of the
spark offering you still have to like to
make the connections and not not you
know you can start our spark but our
spark garb but if you want to use our
studio you have to make the connections
again git and github codex you know file
compression decompression that sort of
thing curl w guys so they can pull data
from the web loaded into your cluster
whatever and access to data on h and on
HDFS for kind of what i call last mile
computing actually i think that's a term
I I borrowed from Ben Ben last mile
computing yeah so um you know and the
focus really here is about the
practitioner so raise your hand if
you're part of a small team like maybe
you're a part of a small tech company or
you're doing
science work but you have to also do you
know set up a cluster and like do all
the sort of stuff raise your hand okay
so this talk is really geared for you if
you're part of a larger organization
that has a data engineering team and has
a conformal DevOps team and it has a
running infrastructure I mean you can
certainly use some of the things I want
to talk about here but that's not the
use case the news piece is really about
like small agile R&D you're taking a
class you want to do with title
competition you want to use big data
right you want to like if you want to
set up these tools so that they work for
you that's the goal here again your
small team you're doing consulting work
you're working for a client you want to
instantiate you gets a lot of data you
got a few terabytes of data you want to
do something with it what do you do your
set up cluster so a lot of these what
are called what I'm calling transient
infrastructure it's because you set it
up you run it you use it for a period of
time maybe you start it up and you shut
it down you start ripping and in the
future and things like that over and
over and over so also you want to share
this environment with multiple users a
lot of the tutorials out there you can
start a cluster and run it but it's
really geared to using you know a single
user name and password what does it want
to set it up for multiple users etc so
separate kind of use case is and this
this little ones can hold before it
works one so I think AMR's made great
strides in the last year in sort of
their offering but up to some time ago
the Hadoop version running on Amazon's
EMR was wasn't the open-source version
so it was kind of like lagging behind so
important works was always like the
latest and greatest so you know to your
point about which one is better so there
is a difference right so the question
before was you wanted really this bc to
any and elastic MapReduce okay so let's
let set two definitions one is so easy
to write is Amazon's virtual machine
offering right easy to is just of
machine on the clock it's just a certain
EMR is managed to do on ec2 so what EMR
does is elastic MapReduce starts up your
machines installs to do
configures can do to run if you start a
cluster of ten machines as it when you
start a clustered usually takes a few
minutes to start out that's because
there's a lot of software being
installed on a machine when it starts so
it's installing and configuring to do
it's in selling it and forget to do to
work with the Amazon easy to
infrastructure you can start a cluster
using ec2 machines and set up your own
for example you captioning start port
works on let's say you start and virtual
machines you can software it works in
each of those machines I don't know if
one is better than the other I mean the
amazon one works on amazon's
infrastructure it's optimized for
amazon's infrastructure there's the
extra premium pay for the managed
service and has a lot of stuff out of
the box portmore so you have to install
anything from scratch so there's a lot
of actually some of some of the files
i'm going to show you are actually i
used when installing part works on easy
to UM but the point is again I just want
to make a point that that it's really
about focusing on sort of that transient
infrastructure that are in the
environment that a possibility of having
to use and reuse over and over again
over perhaps a short period of time not
a production system if you're going to
set up a production system again let the
let the experts do that I'm not a
production guy but again you know you
want to set up these tools to do the
work that you want to do oh there's also
commercial products that allow you to do
some of the things we're going to talk
about here but again let's say you're
taking a class I want to do big data you
want to participate in calc competition
you're doing a research project I mean
you might have acted some of the
commercial tools and education for free
but the reality is you know there's
usually a high price to entry in these
types of things so how do you do this
the hard way um the hard way is again
and I'm thinking so you can apply this
over many different setups right the
setup that comes to mind mostly is cloud
whoever you wherever your pluck favorite
writer is whether
on Google Rackspace whatever or let's
say you have a bunch of old machines
lying in your house and put them
together you can do that but again you
would have to you know start each
machine up then log into each machine
installed software you probably have
like a set of commands that you're on so
they can download the software you
installed it etc you know most of us
live to be lazy right and make what easy
so the ROI right don't repeat yourself
away you can do it several ways you can
use it man line using shell scripts on
Amazon's there's a cold blue strip
actions you know it's a shell script
that starts when you start up your
cluster or another tool meant to talk
about today which I really like it's uh
it's in it's called ansible raise your
hand if you've heard of ansible before
okay so a good number of you have great
so for those of you that haven't ansible
is it's an open source tool it is
written in python and it's really it's
really simple straightforward it's a
tool that allows you to manage and
configure remote systems that doesn't
require anything on the remote system to
be able to use it all you need is an ssh
connection which you get when you start
stuff on the 5 i'm going to show you
kind of web script that yeah no script
looks like and is that it is written in
Python and before I started using the
first 100 to be as well probably about a
year or rich ago or maybe a little over
than that I was looking into some of the
other tools out there like a chef and
puppet personally I found those harder
to work with when I learned about in
civil I thought it was like really easy
again because you don't you don't it's
and for my purposes it works i'm not
saying it's the solution but it's a
solution so and you know the nice thing
about ansible is that it has really a
whole bunch of different modules so i
just want to give you a you know ansible
is a it's actually just a python program
that issues it connects your machine and
issues a whole bunch of commands using
python most infrastructure out of the
box most virtual machines have a version
of python running out of the box so
updated and things like that but most of
these will work and it has a whole slew
of different kinds of things that you
can do you know identity management file
modules and it also has cloud Mudge's it
does work with Amazon it does work with
google it does work with rackspace i
believe so again my experience has been
mostly around amazon services i wanted
to show you what a a script looks like
so it's again it's y amal yet another
markup language and as you can see you
know you have a host file and their ways
to automate the generation of that hosts
file and what it does is it
automatically like you know logs into
each of your machines and it installs
the software you want it you can do like
here is this is this is actually an
ansible script that I use to some
install port and works on ec2 I'm not
going to get into much of the specifics
but for example like I'm copying my
private key up to the server setting up
the hosts file which you need to there's
a lot of soap you know if you wanted us
all to do from scratch you have to do a
lot of stuff which if you are if you
don't have the experience it can be able
so that's why things like for example
elastic MapReduce on Amazon or Google's
cloud offering are easier because they
already give you a noob environment but
what you want to use a lot of these
tools for is really like that that that
additional customization because some of
these some of these for example have are
installed some of them don't so if you
want to install are you have to install
it if you want to install our studio you
have to install it so those are the
types of things that you want to work
with you know and this is this is
actually not much nicer as sort of the
alternate the other alternative which is
a shell script so this is a bootstrap
script actually I'm given to me by one
of the AWS engineers that installs are
in our studio for example so if i wanted
to start up a Hadoop cluster an EMR
cluster with our studio configured and
things like that I have to set this
script as the bootstrap action but it is
a shell scripts a bash script and you
have to understand bash scripting right
you have to tell it do certain things on
the host do certain things on the nodes
etcetera etcetera so it can get pretty
hairy I like it this is not a manageable
but this is
personal preference I like ansible
because it's easier to use and it's kind
of more human language driven than
called a machine language driven so once
you kind of get the hang of it it's it's
really easy to do lots of things so here
are some of the issues to consider when
doing that migration right again you
might want to install are so you have to
download our and install it you know if
you're in a security look again the use
cases you're using something like Amazon
or the cloud maybe not isolated you know
not Material security invited so again
thinking more RND than production
because production has a whole other set
of issues they have to deal with like
security isolation etc so i'm thinking
more again RND exploratory analysis I
want to learn the tools I want to play
with them I want to like really do some
cool stuff so if you wanted to use like
for example are with Hadoop you would
have to have our installed or download
and install it or update a more recent
version I'm not sure what the latest EMR
release version of our is but it's
usually like one or two cycles behind
you do have to install additional
packages if you want to use them so
that's part of something you have to do
there is a flex there's this set of
tools called our Hadoop which is a set
of five different packages this is just
the link just is just the website so
there's five five different packages
some of them one of us all on the head
node or the gateway node installed on
each of them so this allows you to do
streaming or kind of you know it
basically are is issuing kind of a map
of MapReduce job but it you have to make
hugs you have to set up the connections
and and again there's a lot of
information out there and how to get
that done and the and you can do that
again using either a shell script or a
boot structure action script or ansible
um again setting up our studio none of
the none of the offerings that I know of
come with our studio so you have to set
it up and download the server version
and open up the ports so that you can
access it
you have all their security things so
again I'm just like listing sort of
things to think about and things that
you have to take care of in order to get
to that ideal environment anaconda most
offerings that i know of again have
Python but you might want to work with
anaconda because of all of the different
sauter tools that it has right so you
have to download anaconda you have to
you know install it a specific directory
you have to link sometimes linking you
have to put in your path so that each
node you know because remember on
cluster each note is individual but I
each note is sort of its own self each
each notice its own self-contained
machine everything that you want to use
has to usually has to be installed in
each part of the total cluster there are
ways to ship additional things with your
jobs but ultimately sometimes you still
want to be able know that you have a
homogeneous set up across your entire
cluster user management right so for
example if you start up an EMR cluster
the people i think that the bulk user is
called like ec2 dash user you use your
sh t if you install our studio you you
know you can use these to user but
sometimes you need to specify a separate
user name and that user name doesn't
have to do permissions so again you know
I'm not necessarily giving you like all
the solutions because I don't know the
solutions this has been working progress
for a long time and I still haven't come
to a place where I can tell you like
have something that really works out of
the box because stuff keeps changing but
these are the issues that you you know I
just want to make these issues known
because not many people talk about them
and it for me it's been really
frustrating especially as students come
to class and they want to learn about
big data concepts and um you know most
people want to do big data the most
people want to do but they don't
necessarily take into consideration like
all of the systems thinking that goes
into being able to use these tools and
I'm not saying you have to be an expert
in this but I do what I'm saying is you
do need to be aware of these of these
issues um again get so some of the
awesome some virtual machines have get
out of the box some of them don't if you
don't have them you want to install it
you want to use get or
hug for two reasons one is a lot of the
ansible scripts and our shell scripts of
course they're just those are just txt
files so you can put them in version
control using git and github or
whichever version control system you
want to do but the other thing is let's
say you do a lot you need development
and you're developing your machine your
code up to github and you want to pull
that code into your cluster you have to
clone your rebound so in order to do
that you have to you know specify that
you want to clone a specific repo you
can do all these things using the tools
on I mentioned before but for example
you have to put the github host as a
known hostname otherwise your get an
error message up front you can get over
it but you want to automate the idea
here is is about automation and
replicability um so again I just wanted
to sort of highlight some of these
issues there's a lot of there's a lot of
tools out there there's a lot of
material out there I try to condense
them into a 25 to 30 minute presentation
at least to raise the issues and give
you things to think about but you know
I've highly things that have worked for
me and your mileage may vary so uh you
know the way I'm thinking about this is
more as an infrastructure-as-a-service
right is this idea that I can actually
set up an infrastructure of using
scripts because as your research as your
analytics become repeatable so does your
infrastructure and yes I know that there
are ways to manage code versions or
infrastructure versions and dependencies
and things like that but again it's
really the idea that you can script your
I need to start a class let's say you're
working you're doing some consulting
work and you're doing working for client
and you know you have the data you start
up your cluster you configure it a
certain way and you shut it down and
then you need to start it up again
because you need to do something else or
you get new data in the future right
because this is not something you're
going to have running all the time
that's that's the advantage of the
elastic framework how do you replicate
that so you want to have your setup also
replicated you know there are lots of
tools being developed so things like
spark our PI spark these those are
coming as part of the spark offering
some of them work out of the box some of
them
don't you still have to do the hook so
that you want to use for example you
want to use Jupiter notebook as your
front end to a spice Park you have to
set that up I mean it just necessarily
work out of the box and you know again I
just want to reiterate that this is not
intended for production environments let
the let the real DevOps people handle
that work with them and tell them what
you need but you know when you're trying
to get set up and doing that exploratory
work you don't necessarily know what you
want so you probably like you know throw
as much as you can do it and once you
figure out what you want then you then
you make it a repeatable
production-ready capability and you know
I couldn't do my job today if it weren't
for the internet so a lot of the
information I'm talking about today is
out there I'm trying to condense it i
will post the slides and i will add a
couple of different links but yeah you
know really thanks to many many
different people that have been out
there especially the open source
community and the folks that are
actively developing a lot of the
projects that were using on a daily
basis so that's it thank you very much
this is my contact information I invited
you to come check out the different
events we have meetups usually every
different month and get involved with
community so thank you very much and I'm
happy to answer questions yeah
it is i can show i have i can show you
some scripts that i have so for example
this this one so this is the actual
gamal that that issues all the different
modules the different ansible modules to
do specific tasks yeah so in the end it
I'll show you so this one is actually
let me see where I have it
so with ansible what you do is you I
have a configuration file that first
line this is this is just a batch script
so this is a bash script that invokes
ansible with using certain
configurations so you know uh where is
it so just to give you an idea so here
here's here's a configuration file that
i have that sets up a whole bunch of in
Barney's are all bash bash environment
variables that get passed in danceable
that call in the Amazon command-line
interface to start a cluster so I'm
actually in here I'm actually for
specifying this is what I was playing
around with trying to install
Hortonworks on on easy to not using
elastic MapReduce but just like studying
you know starting six machines and then
deploying on Bari to all of the
different nodes so that I download HTTP
and then install it so there's a whole
bunch of different parameters are going
to play here so I have one master node I
supposed to tie the tie this um actually
specify the spot price so so you can
parametrize a lot of these things but
it's a combination of it's sort of a
combination of script on top of script
on top of script it's there's it's a lot
I think it's a lot of kind of hacking in
a certain way there's no real
out-of-the-box way to do it you can I'm
sure there's easier ways but this is
just one way but so exact you know this
passes in the parameters to the ansible
which uses I think it actually doesn't
use the CLI use this boat 0 which uses
we need to specify your AWS credentials
to do this so you it's what it does is
actually this if I go to the stum the
Amal know so here I'm like invoking this
these are just like a different here is
I'm actually running a playbook with
certain parameters this is humans all
instances so in this one this is like a
common setup so what this is doing is
well first of all what it does in this
case there's strip wish instantiates
machines and then it gets it gets the
domain IDs from those machines and
creates a host file that ansible then
used to communicate to all the different
machines so you know it's it's it's a
process yeah ideally ideally yes but
again I still haven't been able to fully
like have I'd have to have multiple to
do all the things that I want to do I've
been played around with little bits and
pieces of it i still haven't packages it
all together that's kind of my grander
vision is to create a set of like
ansible playbooks that allows you to
sort of you know press a button go get
coffee come back half hour later and you
have a Hadoop cluster up and running set
up the way you wanted to do it so I mean
there is debugging involved here
sometimes it breaks so so it's like
everything else right its development
and again this is you could you know
this is not necessarily applied to data
science per se but it's just part of the
it's just part of the issues of dealing
with systems which a lot of people don't
talk about and it restricts the heck out
of me so but but yeah so this is cool i
really like this again i think it's an
easier way to do it I think the tools
are coming a long way I really do I mean
I'm hoping that probably I don't know
when but maybe that they're there be
more modular offerings where you could
actually like invoke EMR with all these
things already pre-configured for you I
don't know I mean they may may may or
may not do it I'm not sure yeah
here DevOps is an enterprise software
development phrase used to mean a type
of Angela ratio between development and
IT operations well DevOps I think DevOps
in the in like the the true sense of the
term as it got coined was really about
having your development team work hand
in hand with your IT team and when I say
the IT team is these are the folks that
are actually like running the machines
and and doing all the maintenance and
the development team is developing stuff
so developed in themes like handing
stuff over to IT they are putting it
into production it's to create this like
more integrated culture I like the term
just because it's like you're doing both
development and operations but again in
this in the case for us right here is
really within the context of data
science and in setting up your
environment any more questions well
thank you very much I hope you enjoyed
the talk